there's something cursed about this land  our family  moved west on a promise  a promise that now looked rotten  there's no room for boys in this family  anymore  and no one warned my brother about what  can happen when you dream about  destiny that's how alison wells  entered this story  [Music]  the thief and murderer allison wells  sent five human souls to heaven if you  see this woman  do not confront her  you okay  somebody's gonna pay me 20 000 to get  them to mexico can you even imagine that  much money  we got to get all the farmers and we got  to search  i need to get out of here you're hunting  me  you found her ain't ya the wolf lady  it's complicated you know the worst part  of dying is king  is being forgotten  [Music]  it's not safe me being here  [Music]  or for any of us for that matter  [Music]  i won't be another victim of their lives  scared ass yeah me too  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you